what happens when 800 of the world's
most elite footballers and their
managers live together under one roof
play a stop being polite and start
getting real this is the champion and
for my next week I will make myself
reappear as a relevant player now that
the transfer window is over I can spend
more time pursuing my hobbies
you know like playing football hi this
is me Christian Eriksen I love to play
football for Tottenham Hotspur I'm so
happy no hello
watch out Champions League it's time for
a land at a rocky world its Atalanta
gosh
[Music]
money
[Music]
today's arrival day and I'm really
excited to be in the Champions League
mansion with a club that actually has a
chance to make it out of the group stage
oh sorry I didn't see you you must have
been in my shadow or while you talk ciao
listen I know that you feel a lot of
pressure because to be compared to me
this must be very hard I don't I really
haven't thought about baby baby Shh it's
okay it's okay you just be the best job
Felix that you can be because there will
never be anyone who can match my skills
or my amount of troph my good looks here
I want you to take this
it is trophy from something I don't
remember well the Nations League Cup oh
man I don't deserve this I think it
should go to our best player
oh thank you but you know I already have
too many trophies
no I meant para nada
it here is the kitchen
whoa so I decided to take lookie ovitch
under my wing I even let him into my
elite society Lucas of Real Madrid okay
so this is Pirlo vine dispenser you want
wine
this is Maradona flour dispenser I like
to pay for something what is this one do
oh that's a Ballon d'Or it's supposed to
make people care about you but it does
not seem to work
hi we are lads looks like we're taking
over the man United room I think I found
four Lanie's or dare I think I've found
Alexis soldiers huh you know you would
transfer to inter right good talk any of
you Englanders want some swine Kirsten
Germany definitely changed me but now
I'm in the Premier League so I'm trying
to make an effort to understand British
culture in it so what the heck is up
with this brexit thing Christian stop
talking listen Gabriel I swear I'm going
to find a way to get you one ball
you're just to Ireland it ah
[Music]
Jurgen my worthy German rival my classy
Catalan competitor Champions League
trophy
very nice hmm Premier League trophy
very nice my doctor says whenever I get
the trophy craving I should just put in
a commemorative DVD to remind me that
it's really about the journey not the
destination so much it was a good run at
I act but I'm very excited to join
Juventus because well mainly they're
paying me a lot of money hey Georgia my
brother so excited to be in the squad
but sir no transfers over there like
this is so much a new blood my children
are you willing to serve to sacrifice
for the old lady very good for she needs
a de fresh and new blood to stay strong
to stay on
we'll be your Vance's wait aren't
vampires supposed to like not being the
Sun vampire I'm not a vampire
no he just drains their life of everyone
who plays with him
[Music]
[Music]
hit the subscribe button to support our
show and get notified about the new
episodes that way you can be addicted to
our videos and not to cigarette